the Joe Rogan experience but you have to
be able to call out [ __ ] that's wrong on
your side and this is one of the
problems that the Democratic Party's
having right now with this Joe Biden guy
you guys got to be able to call it out
you can't let this slide because
everybody else sees it and Trump is
going to eat him alive he's gonna eat
that guy alive the guy can barely
remember what he's talking about while
he's talking do you know which one it
was cuz there's a few videos there's a
few of them play any of them they're all
right they're all crazy every video of
him recently talking he's stumbling
through [ __ ] he forgets what he's
talking about we should be making those
masks we should be moving on those
ventilators we can do that why doesn't
he just act like a president that's a
stupid way to say sorry he's done no no
I probably best I don't he's like Junior
soprano it's not that's the that's not
even the worst example that's just an
example the one down there when he's
talking to that lady I think that one
was a struggle too that was a struggle
fest and people at home are you at all
concerned as Trump says yeah this is it
not let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself we have to take care of
the cure
that will make the problem worse no
matter what no matter what we know what
has to be done we know you have to
reassess the recommended period yeah see
he doesn't know what he's talking about
when he's talking and this is not like
this I'm looking at this like a medical
condition okay I'm looking at this like
okay when I'm calling a fight and I see
a guy limping and I'm like I think he
heard his name like Thiago Santos
against John Jones I think he hurt his
knee there I think there's something
going on with his knee like that's what
I'm looking at this I'm looking at this
like this is a medical issue that's not
a normal way to communicate less he's
high as [ __ ] because if I was high I'd
be like I don't know what I just said to
this lady blasted or edibles going what
are we even talking about I don't think
that's what it is I think he's oh he's
and I think he can't it's it's he
doesn't look good either and they got
makeup on him his skin is all pulled
tight like a lizard
he's got the button
Governor Cuomo that's I love this
behavior I loved his attitude so flood
and he's been honest and I'm telling you
if unless you're a [ __ ] idiot just go
to any street corner in New York you
know looking [ __ ] footage from July
light it's too many people it's too many
people it's to go I couldn't even think
about get on a ferry Rudy's like I was
staying somewhere on Park Avenue and I'm
like I gotta get into an uber which I'm
[ __ ] filthy okay when you walk into
an uber people are sitting in cars with
the windows shut breathing whatever he's
breathing
yep I open up the car unless you guys
are you gonna get in yeah give it a
minute and then take my handy wipe out
and lower the window and close the
[ __ ] door boom I got it when I get on
the ferry I stand outside I don't sit in
there
I breathed that Hudson River air that's
good for you that's as good as it's
gonna get infected all those bodies and
[ __ ] floating in there
that [ __ ] maluca dust in there and
pollution whatever the [ __ ] is in there
but I know look at within weeks
Teaneck right Teaneck was one that got
contaminated a portly got it you know
that's all my [ __ ] neighborhood
though I don't think nobody a hobo can
was really bad hobo got about from the
cops out of going there [ __ ] was like
a party
Michael Balkan didn't give a [ __ ] like
they were [ __ ] just having orgies in
Hoboken Geno told me you got to say it
really so they finally had to go down
and they closed Hoboken like you weren't
a lot to go into Hoboken only people who
lived in Hoboken
good party in Hoboken then they just had
a [ __ ] to shut it down somebody had a
meme on their page but it might have
been Darnell
I forget who what no madman snoop I
don't remember who it was but anyway
they had a meme on their page
said you tell people you're gonna put
them in jail if they go out after 8 p.m.
but you're letting people out of jail
early because they got the coronavirus
and there's someone going hmm like what
like what the [ __ ] what are you saying
are you gonna lock people up but you're
letting people out you know if if you
looked at this whole thing there's been
some weird people of God test they got
tests I think I tested his [ __ ] name
is angel Elba yeah the black dude that
got shot well he lives in England and he
got tested because he was in contact
with other people that had it
[Applause]